how do we deal with Revelation
3:12 right Revelation
3:12 Jesus Christ Our Lord has a God
over him Jesus says he has a God over
him Revelation 3:12 Revelation 3:12
let's read
it him that overcometh will I make a
pillar in the temple of my God and he
shall go no more out and I will write
upon him the name of my God and the name
of the city of my God which is New
Jerusalem which cometh down out of
Heaven from my God and I'll write upon
him my new name notice four times the
the Lord Jesus Christ four
times the Lord Jesus Christ four times
refers to the father as his God and he's
in glory now Jesus is exalted he's in
heaven he's enthrone with the father as
king of kings and Lord of lords and yet
even in heaven in his exalted State he
refers to the father as his God four
times my God my God my God my God now to
prove to you that Jesus is saying this
in his exalted state in his glorious
position as king of kings and Lord of
lords Revelation 1 verse
5 Revelation 1 verse
5 and from Jesus Christ who's the
faithful witness the first begot of the
dead and the prince of the kings of the
earth unto him that loved us and washed
us from our sins in his own blood so
he's what the prince of the kings of the
earth he's the ruler of the kings of the
earth he rules them and he's in glory
glorified luminous right so he's not in
a state of
humiliation he's in an exalted position
Revelation
17:14 Revelation
17:14 and the lamb shall overcome them
for he is Lord of lords and king of
kings and they that are with him are
called and chosen and faithful so he's
Lord of lords King of Kings King of
Kings Lord of lords right okay so then
why would Jesus still refer to God as as
his God the father as his god well let's
go to Jeremiah 32:27 behold I am the
Lord the God of All Flesh is there
anything too hard for me the true god
Jehovah is the God of All Flesh right
here's my question to you if Jesus the
Eternal Word the Son of God becomes
flesh and not the father and he becomes
flesh to be the father's
servant would it shock you then that
after Jesus becomes flesh to be the
father servant the father becomes his
God John
1:14 John 1:4
and the Word was made flesh the word
became flesh and dwelt among us and we
beheld his glory the glory of the only
begotten of the father full of grace and
truth so Remington Smith since Jesus
became flesh to serve the
father would that surprise you that
after Jesus becomes flesh the father
then becomes his
God okay now let me add to it after
Jesus's resurrection after Jesus was
raised from the dead
is Jesus still in a flesh body a body of
flesh made Immortal and destructible he
still man Remington so he's still flesh
right he's still a man so then why would
it shock you that if he's still flesh
he's still man the father still is God
in heaven
right should that shock
you now let me show you that he's still
man in heaven he's still flesh in heaven
let's to Revelation 22:16 okay
Revelation 22:16 Remington Smith listen
to
this I Jesus have sent my angel to
testify unto you these things in the
churches I'm the root and The Offspring
of David the Bright Morning Star
rementin Smith we're going to post it
again for your benefit one more time I
Jesus have sent my angel to testify unto
you these things in the churches I am
right now in heaven in glory I am the
root and The Offspring of David so
Remington Smith let me ask you a
question how can Jesus still be a
physical Offspring a descendant of David
if he's not
man could he be but he is The Offspring
of David right Remington Smith he goes
right now in heaven I Am The Offspring
of David what does that
mean what does that mean so now
Revelation tells you he's still a man in
heaven he still has a physical body of
Flesh in heaven but glorified the only
difference is is Jesus's physical flesh
body is Immortal indestructible
deathless that's the only thing now the
difference is the body of Flesh yet on
Earth could get tired grow old and be
put to death when the body was raised
it's made deathless Immortal
indestructible just like our bodies will
be when he
comes now Remington you I'm going to
give you a few ver more verses to show
you that Jesus has a body of Flesh a
body of flesh made deathless
Immortal
indestructible do you want
it okay Luke
24 36- 43 paying attention to verse
39 Luke 24 36- 43 pay attention
39 and as they Thus Spoke Jesus himself
stood in the midst of them and saith
unto them peace be unto you but they
were terrified and affrighted and
supposed that they had seen a spirit and
he said unto them why are you troubled
and why do you why do thoughts arise in
your hearts now watch here 39 everyone
39 behold my hands and my feet that it
is I myself handle me and see for a
spirit hath not Flesh and Bones as ye
see me have see I have Flesh and Bones
Spirits don't have Flesh and Bones after
the resurrection Jesus saying look I
have a body of Flesh and Bones I'm not a
spirit I am human with a body of Flesh
and Bones and then he eats food
and when he had thus spoken 4243 brother
I don't know what happened to you I
think Joe Biden came to your house and
when he had thus spoken he showed them
his hands and his feet and while they
yet believed not for Joy because they
were shocked and astonished and wondered
he said unto them have ye here any meat
4243 and they gave him a piece of
broiled fish and of a honeycomb and he
took it and did eat before
them
right John
20 24- 27
John 20
24-27 but Thomas one of the 12 called
damus was not with them when Jesus
came right the
other disciples therefore said unto him
we have seen the Lord but he said unto
him now notice Remington everyone else
what Thomas is asking to touch except I
shall see in his hands the print of the
nails and put my finger into the print
of the nails right and thust my hand
into his side I will not believe see
Thomas is assuming if Jesus has been
raised then that means his body has been
raised because to the Jews first century
Jews did not believe in a resurrection
that wasn't bodily so when you have
Heretics like Greg Stafford a Joe's
Witnesses saying Jesus was resurrected
as a spirit creature that's alien to
Judaism of the first century to a Jew
when you say Resurrection it's bodily
that body that died and dis
disintegrated is is now recreated and
resurrected and made Immortal that's why
I saying wait wait wait Jesus has been
raised then that means he has that body
that body that was nail that means the
holes in his hands are still there and
the hole in his side well I got to touch
that body to see if the holes are there
to be convinced so what happens now 26
to 27 and after eight days a week later
again his disciples were with him within
inside and Thomas with them then came
Jesus the doors being shut and stood in
the midst and said Peace be unto you now
notice 27 post 27 again okay then sayith
he to Thomas reach hither thy finger
reach here and behold my hands and reach
hither thy hand thrust it into my side
be not faithless but believing what is
Jesus asking Thomas to touch if Jesus
didn't have a physical body if Jesus
wasn't raised in that physical body that
was beaten whipped and nailed now raised
and made immortal what is he asking him
to
touch everyone got
it and then in verse 28 what is Thomas's
reaction in verse 28 and Thomas answered
and said unto him my Lord and my God and
Thomas answered and said unto him my
Lord and my God I'm convinced now you
are my Lord my God In the Flesh I don't
need
convincing Romans 6 verses 7 to10
specifically verses 8 to9 what kind of
body does Jesus have Romans 6 7 to 10
specifically 8 to9 for he that is dead
is freed from sin now if we be dead with
Christ we believe that we shall also
live with him knowing that Christ being
raised from the dead dieth no more Jesus
cannot die anymore death had no more
dominion over him for in that he died he
died to sin one time he died because of
our sins once but in that he liveth he
liveth unto God did you catch it did you
guys catch it are you paying
attention by the power of the Holy
Spirit Jesus died because of our sins
but now he's been raised and is
deathless he can never die anymore death
has no dominion over him so the body of
Christ that is flesh and Bone can that
body be destroyed can that body die ever
again what kind of bodies will we have
like his body when he raises our
physical bodies he'll make them Immortal
indestructible deathless like
his Hebrews
7:16 who is made not after the law of a
carnal commandment but after the power
of an endless life let's read it again
Hebrews 7:16 one more
time Hebrews 7:16
a power of an endless life his life is
endless indestructible
deathless but wait he exists in that
physical body of Flesh and bone that
means his physical body of Flesh and
Bone deathless endless Immortal
indestructible Hebrews 7
24-2 but this man because he continu
forever he continu ever hath an
unchangeable priesthood wherefore he is
able also to save them to the uttermost
that come unto God by him seeing that he
ever liveth he ever lives to make
intercession for
them potato yes you'll be made Immortal
indestructible morally Incorruptible you
can never sin ever again and never die
again okay Philippians 3:20-21
Philippians 3:20-21
for our conversation meaning our
citizenship is in heaven Philippians
3:20-21 is in heaven from Once from
there also we look for the Savior the
Lord Jesus Christ who shall change our
vile body he's going to change this vile
body that's prone to
sin you know lust and perversion and and
failing to honor God and obey God and
and other Wicked disgusting things and
grows old and decrepit and gets sick
sick and disease that vile body that it
may be fashioned like unto his glorious
body according to the working whereby he
is able even to subdue all things unto
himself did you catch
it by his power his Almighty power his
power that's infinite that power that
enables him to subject everything to
himself and destroy everything that
opposes him that power that Jesus
possesses that's the power that enables
him to change our vile bodies to be like
his glorious body